moving on to other things how about
covid right covet
horrible all across the country
but as usual i'm going to start right
down here in my home state of florida
where as we know
our trump-loving republican governor ron
desantis
has said and they doubled down again on
this on friday
that any school district
that implements a mass mandate which is
a growing number of them at this point
we may cut off your funding
now according to reports on friday and
this really angered me because these
reports are totally inaccurate they said
that desantis had backed off
his claim to cut the salaries of
administrators
who uh go along with these mass mandates
instead
what actually happened was you had a
desantis spokesperson christina pusha
who came out and said we're gonna leave
it to the to the school boards
to voluntarily give up their salaries
for doing this once we cut their funding
so they didn't exactly back off it they
just realized oh wait we actually don't
have the authority to do it so we're
going to explain how it can be done but
we're still going to cut off your
funding they said
so over the weekend the biden
administration came out did the right
thing and said hold up now
any school district in the state of
florida oh and before i even get into
that biden actually called
some of the districts and thanked them
for putting mass mandates in place so
that was a good job as well biden is not
backing down off this he is making sure
that these people know he has their back
and so after the phone calls his
administration came out and said
anywhere in the state of florida
if they cut off your funding for having
a mask mandate
we got your back and we'll make sure you
get the funding
if we have to we will use some of these
covet emergency funds
to fund your school district to pay your
salaries to do whatever we need to do
because we're not going to let this
florida tyrant
tell you
to make these horrible decisions that
could put your kids in danger
across the state in county after county
including counties that defied desantis
and did put mask mandates in place
we are seeing record numbers
of teachers administrators and students
out with covid or
having to quarantine because of exposure
broward county i think the number was
what 440
out you also had four teachers in
broward county all die last week within
hours of each other
from covid
reopening these schools with no mask
mandates at all no vaccine mandates for
teachers or administrators
was one of the biggest mistakes we have
seen this
this state do
you know last year
they started doing
away with the virtual learning with the
distance learning
forcing most people to go brick and
mortar this year distance learning was
not even an option
it was brick and mortar or you become a
full-time homeschooler
and that's why we're seeing so many
problems we did we didn't even we didn't
have the option
we weren't given a choice
the only choice we have is whether or
not we personally send our kids to
school wearing a mask which yes i have
done
when i drop them off they have their
masks on when i pick them up they still
have their masks on i have no idea what
happens all throughout the day though
with those masks
are they taking it off as soon as i drop
them off
are they putting it on when they see me
walking up i don't know
and i don't know what any of the other
children are doing there either except i
do know when i go to pick them up in the
afternoon there's only a handful of kids
wearing masks and i've only seen one
staff member wearing a mask when i've
gone to pick up my children one
this situation is about to become so
much worse
we're now a full week down
hundreds of people throughout the state
as a result of exposure at school either
on quarantine
or
out with covid
and it's going to get worse as time goes
on because we're not protecting our kids
desantis said he left the decision up to
the parents well the parents aren't
making the right decision here
and they're letting their kids get
exposed who then expose other children
all we have to do is have our kids wear
masks they had to do it all throughout
the school year last year
do you know how many problems it caused
none
there were no reports of any child being
injured from having to wear a mask
there was not mass hospitalizations
because children's oxygen levels dropped
due to wearing a mask
one of our sponsors today is blue chew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping